all right I am back from vacation the
whole team is back I'll have some pretty
good vacation stories actually from very
sunny and humid Aruba on today's bonus
show but one of the things that I did
during the break or I guess sort of
didn't do I completely tuned out
political news and really news of all
kind during the vacation and then when I
got back I started the process of
catching up on what I'd missed to be
ready for today's show and it gave me
some really good perspective in a sense
I missed a ton including a ton of
erratic unhinged statements and actions
from Donald Trump and yet here we are
ten days since the last new show and in
a sense nothing has changed and I want
to see if I can explain it in a very
particular way lots of things happened
while I was gone but nothing changed in
that Trump is still a threat to our
economy Trump is still a threat to the
planet our allies are still disgusted
with Donald Trump and our relationships
with other countries continues to
continue to be worse than they've been
in a very long time and what we have to
understand is that the media outrage
rounds that take place with every stupid
and crazy thing that Donald Trump does
don't change the reality of the policy
that the Donald Trump administration is
putting out there so while I was gone
Donald Trump said migrants at the US
border under US custody won't get the
flu vaccine this is horrible this leads
to actual deaths the administration is
exceeding their own limit for how long
people are supposed to be held and and
ignoring their own limit that they've
placed Trump said Jews who vote for
Democrats are disloyal to Israel which
is of course premise taun a totally
anti-semitic notion of dual loyalty to
Israel in the u.s. that American Jews
supposedly have according to people like
Donald Trump when Danish leadership told
Donald Trump Greenland isn't for sale
Trump erratically canceled his visit
there I mean just the total
embarrassment globally on all fronts
despite having said he was going to push
for gun control a gun background gun
safety regulations in the form of
universal background checks Trump is
bowed to the NRA and said now not
interested in doing those background
checks anymore Trump called himself the
chosen one during another one of these
erratic rants any one of these would
have been a scandal at any point during
the Obama presidency this was one week
of donald trump while i was on vacation
and I'm sure I'm missing things by the
way but in the end nothing changed
during those 10 days the immigration
policy of the Trump administration is a
humanitarian emergency it was before my
vacation and it continues to be our
trade policy was a self-destructive joke
before the break and after it it's worse
now and I'll talk about that later on in
the program I don't mean that there's no
impact for each of the things that
Donald Trump does Trump says no flu
vaccine people die of the flu I mean
this is very real in that sense but what
I mean is that the big picture has not
changed we have an erratic ignorant
megalomaniac who is in charge of the
United States the Republican Party is
half way complicit and half way
indifferent and some sliver actually
likes it and we need to be focused on
making the big changes that will put a
stop to this which starts with removing
the president but it's got to include
taking control aback of the Supreme
Court and the lower courts which
increasingly with every passing month
Donald Trump controls more and more of
we've got to repair the relationships
with other countries you know starting
to be reasonable with people around the
world instead of being the petrel and
child that everyone ignores because
there's no reasoning with them and I've
said this before and I'll say it again
this is a daily show that I do and what
I tell you is what's going on I'm gonna
continue to make the effort to
contextualize it explain why the day to
day matters explain what we can do
something because we need to be doing
more than the outrage porn stuff no one
really benefits from that
this isn't me saying let's bury our
heads in the sand and ignore the news
but it's let's be more thoughtful and
specific about how we work with the news
that we hear
and actually try to turn it into
something activism knowledge that
becomes usable catalyzing voting it's
got to go beyond the outrage porn and
not paying attention to the news for
this week confirm that number one it's
important to pay attention to the news
but we've got to be doing it in a
particular way where we understand that
each individual news story is not
changing or shaping the bigger picture
and the bigger picture is the important
context that we need to understand so
that that's my sort of refocus as I come
back from the vacation and a lot of that
is going to happen immediately on this
show and in fact we've got to go to
trade policy next